it takes three days to unload the j s
missouri at the port of bremen it's
carrying forty one thousand tons of
high-quality iron ore from a mine in
Sweden purchased at a bargain price that
makes the buyers in Germany happy while
the mines that produce the iron ore are
struggling with lower revenues McCunn
off MA I've been put up with prices of
fifty dollars a ton for a certain amount
of time but over the long run that means
no more investment in new capacity at no
reinvestment in running operations so
it's more or less a standstill Eva as a
male of any of you stunned when mines
earn less they cut back on buying new
machinery that something mining
equipment maker caterpillar knows only
too well for years the global
commodities boom kept the company's
order books full now management is
preparing for several years of sluggish
demand yaha Mencia stagnant we're
heavily focused on the future because it
takes us 12 months to fill the normal
backlog of orders so if market
conditions change and prices go down for
example we don't feel the effects until
the following year there's a one-year
delay
production has already slowed down at
caterpillar management wants to take the
opportunity to modernize and replace
aging machinery and equipment the
company has no plans to save during the
downturn when orders pick up again
caterpillar wants to be one step ahead
of the competition especially chinese
companies that are trying to lure away
customers with cheaper machinery
patrouille this emoji phlogiston of
course there's a tendency for customers
to buy cheaper products when times are
tough so we have to demonstrate that our
machinery has the lowest costs per ton
over the entire lifecycle of the product
buyers at the port of Bremen are hoping
the low price of iron ore is here to
stay from here the ore is fed directly
into a blast furnace the iron ore is
smelted into steel which is cheaper now
than it's been for the past 10 years